filed in 2004 by the New York State
Attorney General against GlaxoSmithKline
manufacturer of the antidepressant Paxil
ms bass reports that several sources
claim the manufacturer suppressed
research on the link between paxil and
suicidal thoughts the event hosted by
back pages books in Waltham
Massachusetts is 50 minutes
well good evening thank you all for
coming my name is Alex green I'm the
owner of back pages books here in
Waltham thank you thank you it is a
pleasure to do this tonight it's if
there's often talk about about
newspapers sort of sort of slipping and
you forget the idea of a journalist as a
household name because I think people
forget the idea of journalists who do
good things and they are out there and
seeing people come through the store the
last few weeks you know it's amazing how
many people say they know Allison dass
Allison has done extraordinary work for
years she's an award-winning journalist
she's a professor she's a fellow
graduate of Brandeis University with me
and she is the author of the
extraordinary book side effects a
prosecutor a whistleblower and a
best-selling antidepressant on trial I
want to thank you all for coming
and if you'll join me and please welcome
Allison dance okay well thank you that
was a lovely introduction and I really
appreciate your being here tonight it's
so nice to see so many friendly faces in
the audience at a reading I gave at
Harvard bookstore a couple of weeks ago
there were also a lot of friendly faces
but there were a number of people that I
didn't know and one woman who was
sitting right in the front row stood up
turned around and insisted that I read
the back of her t-shirt so I just want
to note if anybody you want me to read
the back of their team okay all right
Erica once we've got that out of the way
I'm going to talk a little bit about my
book its origins and why the topic is so
relevant today then I'll read a short
passage from the book and open up the
floor to take your questions but first
let's start with a few facts the drugs
that are the focus of my book the
antidepressants the SSRI antidepressants
first selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors have been blockbuster drugs
since the 1990s and they are still among
the top five classes of drugs sold in
the United States today
any depressant prescriptions for
children and adolescents make up a large
chunk of those sales even though there
is no evidence from clinical trials that
they are significantly more effective
than a sugar pill or placebo in treating
depression in children and adolescents
as I reveal in my book the makers of
these antidepressants withheld negative
information about the safety in effect
and effectiveness of these drugs for
instance they withheld the fact that
there is an increased risk of suicidal
thoughts and behaviors in some people
children adolescents adult young adults
and adults taking the drug and
GlaxoSmithKline is currently being
investigated by the United States
Department of Justice for
misrepresenting data in the very study
that I write about in my book and the
members of Congress are also looking at
some of the blatant conflicts of
interest that in my book I contend are
have flawed our system of drug research
as I report in the book the makers of
antidepressants and makers of
antipsychotics and other drugs paid
millions of dollars in personal income
speaking and consulting fees to
researchers who were studying their
drugs and touting their drugs in medical
journals and at conferences there are
very few instructions right now on how
much doctors can personally earn from
the drug industry and even though
they're supposed to disclose these
conflicts of interest many of them don't
so I first became aware or I first began
to get a sense of how flawed the drug
research business is when I was a
reporter for the Boston Globe in the mid
in the 90s it all started with an
anonymous phone call from a woman who
had left a cryptic message with the
globe city desk something about the
misappropriation of funds from a state
mental health agency as I was the
globe's mental health reporter at the
time I got the message it was late in
the day I had just filed a daily under
and I almost didn't return the call but
I picked up the phone and a woman by the
name of Donna Howard answered Donna told
me that she was assistant research
administrator in the department of
psychiatry at Brown University and that
she had in her possession documents
proving that the chief of Psychiatry of
Brown was collecting hundreds of
thousands of dollars from a state mental
health agency for research that
apparently wasn't being conducted she
also told me that she suspected
researchers in the department were
misrepresenting data in two clinical
trials one involving paxil for the
treatment of depression in adolescence I
remember typing quick notes the phone
cradled to my ear thinking this can't be
for real Donna and I agreed to meet the
next day at a Burger King on route 24
she suggested the location because it
was halfway between Providence which is
where Brown is located and Boston Donna
said she'd be wearing a long navy skirt
and had brown hair I told her I was
short no news there and would be wearing
a red winter coat now in my job as a
reporter I ventured into riot torn
ghettos flipped into locked mental
health institutions to investigate
charges of abuse and I've even gone
undercover as a waitress in a restaurant
to investigate labor violations I had a
place in Miami so meeting a stranger in
a Burger King outside of Brockton would
be one of my less adventuresome outings
or so I thought at the time
Donna struck me as being very sincere
someone who had taken an enormous risk
in meeting with a reporter that she
didn't know she told me she was a single
mother raising a severely troubled child
and that she had come to work at brown
because she thought it was doing
important research into the workings of
the human mind
everything Donna told me that morning
was backed up by extensive documentation
and I filed a series of articles in The
Boston Globe about research and billing
transgressions by Martin Callender
Browns chief of Psychiatry then in June
2004 when I read about the New York
State Attorney General's lawsuit against
GlaxoSmithKline the maker of paxil I
suddenly remembered what Donna had told
me almost nine years prior now back then
I hadn't been able to pin down the
allegations about the paxil study of
which Keller was a principal
investigator but now it looked like the
Attorney General's Office had done it
for me so with a few phone calls I
discovered that the brainchild behind
the Attorney General's lawsuit was a
woman by the name of Rose Fierstein a
newcomer to Eliot Spitzer's office thus
another remarkable woman entered the
story in suing the second largest
pharmaceutical company in the world rose
essentially took up the baton that Donna
had hoisted now it wasn't just the
determination of these two women to
fight for the public good that inspired
me to write the book I was fascinated by
them I wanted to know what compelled
Donna to risk her job and speak out true
she was planning to leave Brown anyway
but Martin Keller was a powerful man in
certain circles and he could make it
very difficult for her to ever get a job
in the mental health field again if he
so chose Donna even had federal agents
on her doorstep at one point which is
pretty scary stuff I also wanted to know
what motivated Rose Fierstein to take on
a risky legal case that had no precedent
in New York State in fact up until that
point no state had dared to go after the
drug companies for misleading physicians
and consumers about the effectiveness of
their drugs in essence committing
consumer fraud not only was rose new
to Eliot Spitzer's office but she was
legally blind to boot it was far from a
foregone conclusion that her bosses
would let him proceed with a potentially
explosive case that could backfire at a
very time that Eliot Spitzer was running
for governor what can you do and I'll
entertain questions about that
afterwards anyway how I had to change my
epilogue at the last minute anyway
the more I delved into this case the
more I realized what a dramatic story
that this would make so I like to give
you a taste of what I mean and read a
very short passage from the book ok the
subtitle of this chapter is Donna Howard
talked to the press and becomes a pariah
January 1996 it was dark by the time
Donna Howard pulled into her driveway
but she could see the black Lincoln
Continental parked on the side of the
road an anomaly in her working-class
neighborhood of beat-up pickup trucks
she knew the two men sitting inside the
car were federal agents because one of
them had called her earlier that day at
the hospital he said he was from the US
Postal Service investigating the
possibility of mail fraud Howard didn't
quite know what that meant and she was
afraid to ask the man sounded friendly
enough could he drop by this evening to
talk to her
aghast that a law enforcement agent had
called her at work how did he know her
number anyway Donna tried to quell the
queasiness surging up her throat this
was the last thing she needed right now
thinking fast
Howard told him she had to take her
daughter for a doctor's appointment and
wouldn't be home until after 7 p.m.
that's ok the agent said we don't mind
the late hour
Howard's cottage was isolated a quarter
mile from the nearest neighbor when she
first saw the Continental parked on the
side of the road she had to resist an
impulse to turn around and drive madly
away instead she took a deep breath and
told Maria in his light a tone as she
could muster we've got visitors
I was expecting them as she emerge from
the car the two men got out of theirs
the older man looked to be in his 50s
he was heavyset and balding when he
introduced himself Howard recognized his
voice he was the one who had called her
the other man who was probably in his
40s was built like a football player
muscular brought around the shoulders
with a crew-cut a secret service type
Howard thought shakily as she ushered
the two men inside and invited them to
sit down at her kitchen table her new
puppy Hudson a spaniel collie mix barked
excitedly and ran circles around the
room Maria who was on a new medication
and not feeling well said she was going
to bed
Howard walked her to a room and gave the
puppy some food then she poured herself
in the two agents some water and sat
down at the table the men wanted to know
all about the accusations leveled
against martin keller in the brown
psychiatry department in a page one
story i had written for the boston globe
a few weeks earlier headlined state-paid
school two hundred and eighteen thousand
dollars on falsely billed DMH study the
january 1996 article described how the
massachusetts department of mental
health had been paying Brown psychiatry
department hundreds of thousands of
dollars to fund research that wasn't
being conducted as Donna Howard wearily
answered the agents questions she
wondered not for the first time how she
had gotten into this mess she thought
she had done the right thing by telling
Palestine Grady Hanan the director of
research administration for brown of her
concerns for weeks afterwards Howard her
nothing then one evening
Tancredi Hannon called her at home she
said she had gone to the Dean of the
medical school with the information
Donna had given her but the Dean had
told her to let it go all they had here
he insisted was a bunch of disgruntled
employees
Tancredi hadn't told Howard that she was
sorry there was nothing more she could
do shortly after that conversation
Howard started looking in earnest for
another job she could already sense a
freeze in Carolina Sullivan's attitude
toward her despite her fears that Keller
was on to her the memos and
boxes that Howard had unearthed in the
file room at Duncan ate away at her she
hated the thought that a prestigious
academic institution might be benefiting
at the expense of indigent people with
mental illness so in mid-november as the
treed bears as the trees bared their
limbs and the sandy beaches near her
home turned cold
how will Howard steeled herself and
called the city desk at the Boston Globe
someone there took down her name and
number but no one called back she tried
again this time the message was
forwarded to me and I returned her call
now it was late January and here she was
sitting at her own kitchen table with
two formidable-looking federal agents
asking her the strangest questions she
felt as if she with a suspect in a
gruesome murder trial so what kind of
car does dr. Keller drive the heavyset
agent asked Howard stared at him and
disbelief I have no idea she said she
explained that she worked across campus
from Keller and very rarely saw him do
you know what his wife does no the agent
scratched his balding head and looked at
his companion the younger man who had
been occupied tossing a duel covered
ball to Hudson shrugged mrs. Howard what
possessed you to copy all these
documents and give them to a reporter
the older man finally asked Howard told
him what she had told me that she cared
deeply about the welfare of patients
with mental illness and had been
outraged to learn that at a time of
major cutbacks and services all this
money seemed to be disappearing into the
coffers of a wealthy institution by the
time the agent left close to 10:00 p.m.
excuse me by the time the agents left
close to 10:00 p.m. they were joking
about her puppies ball fetching skills
they thanked Howard for her time and
drove away as she watched their big
black car recede into the darkness Donna
Howard hoped fervently that these were
the last federal agents she would ever
have the privilege of speaking to her
wish would not be granted
so thank you so much for listening and
now I'd love to take your questions
don't be don't be shy there's anybody
wouldn't oh yes go ahead form my form of
it
that's a dr. Barbara elf envy it works
on Sanford Street that's in charge of
GMA now she is the one that is in charge
of the whole state and I want to speak
to her it's like five minutes or ten she
knows who I am
so she told me that there's on profit
and profit there's profit and nonprofit
organizations
now nonprofit and for-profit
organizations look there are social
organizations and that the she has a
budget to put in different sections now
there's something that the DMH does they
have $50 that they have services with
that organization so that $50 from her
budget that she has goes to each client
that's in non-profit and profit so that
what happens is like the organization I
am they lead the money provide services
but like you say new services the amount
of money for salary is low so what in my
ization they are taking a lot of clients
but what's happening is it used to be
like 12 clients but we're getting less
but money they're getting they're saying
Oh little take they take more money
right but the staff would be overwhelmed
where they having double the money so
what's what's your question what I'm
saying is
it's not questions it's a statement that
to what you're saying because the second
thing I want to say is Lily they went
through named Marilyn when he was at
practice and say you diabetes so money
can make different ways like inside it
people just don't realize there's a lot
that people don't realize that that
happens behind the scene and the way
that drugs are tested marketed and sold
in this country thank you any other
questions I think oh go ahead yes I
understand the thesis of the
profitability of the drugs what I'm
wondering about is it's probably true
that there's things that don't cost a
lot of money or vitamins or other or
even drinking a lot of water can benefit
people's mental health and it wasn't
actually an article in today's Wall
Street Journal and water drinking but
the no one does the studies because
there's no real profit motive from any
of the companies that would make those
products of wonder you've had a comment
on getting research done to show that
other types of vitamins are so good
question I mean the problem I think with
searches goodbye nonprofits and so we
have a vested interest as he said in
developing drugs that they think they
can make into blockbuster sales in other
words drugs that they think and get
enormous sales so what happens is a drug
might be approved by the FDA for one
condition as the antidepressants were
originally approved for depression in
treating adults but because the drug
companies want to make them into
something that has blockbuster sales
they market them for what we call
off-label uses which is using a
depressants and showing adolescents even
though they haven't been approved and
using them for other conditions as well
they also do clinical trials in an
effort to convince doctors to prescribe
these drugs for off-label uses the
problem is is that they withheld the
negative findings from those clinical
trials they don't publish those they
only publish what when they find a
that finding so essentially doctors and
consumers in this country are not
getting the full story about the safety
and effectiveness of these drugs so it
is a it's it's a problem yes I think
you're gonna see things get worse before
you see them get better I just got back
from China and I have a woman that's a
good friend of mine who got her her
doctorate in biochemistry at Brandeis
and she is working for a company there
and but she's in the process she's in
the process of coming back but they gave
her the all the drug companies here are
doing a lot of their research and
they're beginning to do clinical trials
because this far less grief given to the
companies mm-hmm about yeah yeah the
results you know right I mean a lot of
the early testing the toxicity the the
safety to see whether these compounds
work in animals for instance yeah a lot
of that might goes overseas they're
still by and large doing clinical trials
here there although it's increasing in
other countries as you say the the one
thing that can keep these clinical
trials because after as a result of this
lawsuit by the New York State Attorney
General's Office a group of the top
medical journals in the world including
the New England Journal of Medicine and
JAMA and a bunch of others required
researchers basically decided to require
start requiring researchers to post the
results of the design or not the results
but the protocol for the designs of
their studies on a publicly available
website so then they couldn't change the
outcome measures in the middle midstream
and come up in other words basically fit
the data to fit fit the results to fit
the outcome measures before that before
that requirement and as I talked about
in this book with paxil they changed in
the middle of the study they changed the
outcome measures because they found out
that they weren't paxil was not
effective was not more effective than
placebo on the two primary
outcome measures it just wasn't and a
lot of some of the other SSRIs as well
had that problem so they actually
changed the outcome measures came up
with some secondary outcome measures
that were not as objective that were
more subjective and it was easier to fit
to the results and they then they
published this paper showing that or
alleging that paxil was more effective
than placebo so this was half this
happens a lot and and that and that's
why now that the medical journals are
requiring them to post the early designs
of the study it's harder for them to
change it it can still happen because
it's hard for people to keep on top of
what's going on but it is more difficult
for them to change the results so in
terms of human clinical trials they
still are held up to certain standards
if they want to get published in the
most prestigious medical journals if
they don't you know there are a lot of
journals that will publish them and
doctors will let you know may pay
attention but most doctors pay more
attention to journals like the New
England Journal of Medicine and because
they trust those journals so yeah yes
I'm from Needham and there's been a
number of young people in Needham and I
think even Wellesley and maybe some
other towns that have committed suicide
and I suspect that some of them may have
been on drugs like this for depression
and have you seen some connections
between suicides and these drugs hidden
well yeah that's I mean that basically
that's a good question because what they
have found this all started back when
prozac was first launched in the late
80s dr. Martin Teicher who I write about
my book was among the first to publish
findings that there was an increased
risk of suicidal thoughts among adults
taking Prozac and there was the FDA
because there was a lot of publicity
around his study which was published in
the American Journal of Psychiatry they
held a public hearing and essentially
they dismissed the findings and then
they went ahead and approved so loft and
we had improved paxil when I had kept
approving antidepressants
and did not take seriously the
allegations that there was this the side
effect in some people now let me hasten
to add that these any depressants are
very helpful for many people they do
work in particularly in older adults
there is evidence from clinical trials
that they work and it's in some people
but if there is in it in a percentage of
people it's because our metabolism our
brain chemistry is different they do
cause agitation and suicidal thoughts
and behaviors and if doctors don't know
about these side-effects and they can't
monitor their patients and take them off
the drugs when they have these side
effects and that's exactly what happened
a lot of people when they started
feeling more suicidal were they just the
doctors just upped the dosage and some
of them killed themselves some of them
tried to and if this was a particularly
bad problem in children adolescence and
it was not until fourteen years after
Mario Teicher first raised the concern
and in large part because of the
publicity from the New York State
Attorney General's lawsuit that the FDA
finally put black box warnings on all
SSRI antidepressant and other
antidepressants warning that there was
this increased risk of suicidal thoughts
and behaviors so the doctors could
monitor patients when they first went on
treatment and during the weeks and
months afterwards so that they were
aware of that so yeah it's it's
definitely a side effect yes fine yeah
go ahead
one the Food and Drug Administration has
been around for about a century yet a
character in your book referred to it as
the foot dragging and alibis for FDA why
is that after 100 years secondly since
your book has been published have you
heard from Donna Howard or Rose
Fierstein in terms of their reaction or
response they've had from your book
third martin keller there at brown do
you know if in the last three weeks
since your book has come out if anything
has happened there so that perhaps
they're looking a little more closely at
his lab
questions Rodney thank you the first one
is well the FDA you know has a long
history of being the nation's premier
public health agency but starting in the
80s with the Reagan administration and
then the first Bush administration they
their resources were severely cut back
at the very same time there was enhanced
pressure to speed up the approval the
review improve all of drugs and they no
longer had the resources they needed so
in 1993 Congress passed something called
the Prescription Drug User Fee Act which
basically asked the industry the drug
industry to start supplementing the
FDA's drug review budget with user fees
now in 93 this was a industry the
industry s allocation was only 7% of the
FDA's entire drug review budget it is
now more than half of the FDA's entire
review budget so many consumer advocates
feel that that makes the FDA beholden to
the very industry it is supposed to
regulate so there has been a lack of
both political will and resources on the
part of the FDA in terms of monitoring
drugs that have already been approved
particularly for off-label uses and it's
been particularly acute in the last
eight years if things are getting a
little better because of Congress now
that it's Democratic controlled is
holding a lot more hearings and putting
their feet to the fire but it's still
not doing as much as it should to
monitor the safety and effectiveness of
drugs once they've been approved for one
specific use so that's the first
question the second question is he I've
heard from rose and and Bharti and and
Donna and they you know that they they
have Rose particularly as heard from a
number of people in fact she she knew
about a review before I did there was
coming so she's very heated she's no
longer working for the attorney
general's office when Elliott Switzer
became governor he lured most of the her
colleagues to work for him at the state
of New York Department of Health and
Human Services and they in turn
recruited rose and so I think she went
over there last fall
and fortunately their jobs are safe
they're there yeah
Lister she's doing she's doing fine
and it's for Martin Keller another
professor at Brown has filed an ethics
complaint against him for
misrepresenting data in the paxil study
of what she was the principal
investigator and there has been no word
publicly from Brown about that but there
are people at Brown that are very
concerned and feel that action should be
taken and I can't really explain why it
hasn't been over these years yes when
the Cady study came out if you're
familiar with that about the
antipsychotic someone yes yes yes I
email them and I asked them why do they
approve drugs that are a hundred times
more expensive than no less efficacious
and they told me they weren't really
concerned about that that all they were
concerned was is a drug better than
placebo not whether it's better than any
of the other drugs on the market for
there or not it's better than placebo
and whether or not it has a risk risk
profile factor that seems okay but what
I've seen happen I've been doing
inpatient psych as a social worker for
28 years
and I've certainly seen you know the
whole generation of all these drugs and
I think that medicines like
antidepressants I think get a lot of
play because the average person can kind
of identify with that but when you start
talking about antipsychotics and what's
really happening with that I to me it's
so much more in a lot of ways a much
more compelling story in the way that
people who really don't have a voice are
just totally being treated in a way that
that none of us would tolerate yeah I
mean I completely agree with you
with the antipsychotics I'm sure all
many of you had read the article I think
it was on the front page of the New York
Times a few weeks ago about three
psychiatrists at Harvard Medical School
who were among the fiercest proponents
of using these powerful psychoactive
drugs the antipsychotics to treat
childhood bipolar disorder as it turns
out they were earning
millions of dollars from the drug come
the very companies that were making the
antipsychotics and they failed to
disclose they feel the fully disclosed
that they were doing that dr. Joseph
Biederman he was earning one point six
million dollars over four years from the
antipsychotic makers and then there were
two others Thomas Spencer another one
anyway it's the same old story I mean
since what dr. Keller was earning over
two years more than a million dollars
from the makers of antidepressant so it
keeps happening and unfortunately there
are the academic centers are not doing a
good enough job of regulating this and
in my opinion they should just say if
they should prohibit researchers who are
earning more than a certain amount
whether it's 10,000 or 20,000 whatever
the amount is from being able to do
research on the drugs from the company
you know by the companies who they're
getting paid privately for I mean that's
just a blatant conflict of interest and
should be regulated in my opinion let me
before let me go get yes david tyll the
stories I just wanted to clarify a
couple of things one is there was
something on the KD study which I know a
very little bit about but I think the
point of the development of some of the
newer antipsychotics was to try to avoid
the effectiveness maybe equal but to try
to avoid some of the potentially
permanent side effects that could occur
or some of the older antipsychotics so I
think that's that was the main plan
yeah and ns4 treatment with medications
like fluoxetine or prozac for children
in adolescence there were there is some
some support for the efficacy in non
drug company sponsored studies as well
including one the multimodal treatment
of adolescents with depression study so
just wanted to you know to study the one
prozac it's under dispute I know you I
know which one you go yeah
I appreciate dr. David is a psychiatrist
so he he knows of what he speaks just
yep and seroquel is preferable to the
side-effect profile of the medicine like
Howell Dahl really needs to be sat down
and discussed because what we're doing
is we're caught inducing in our patients
a metabolic syndrome that's causing
horrific obesity diabetes and
hypercholesterolemia and then you have
to say well is that worse than somebody
not having you know active fees you're
not having dystonia I mean I think
that's a question to be had and I think
well that's that's beyond because I
that's beyond my purview I'm not an
expert on that I think it's important
because this is what happens when you
start having this conversation is that
people accept it expect you to blindly
accept that the side-effect profile is
better when really it's a debatable
issue that was what all right thank you
thank you yes Linda and then and then do
you think it would go over she doesn't
feel comfortable coming up I'm sorry
sounds like you started out with a story
about misuse of funds and then somehow
wound up with a story where the drug
companies were suppressing bad results
how did one story morph into the other
well I had done the I mean that's how I
found out about Donna Howard okay
this because she had come to me about
the misuse of funds and she had told me
at that time about the misrepresentation
of data in the paxil study but like I
said I hadn't been able to pin that down
so even though I wrote about the misuse
of funds for the Boston Globe it wasn't
until after the New York State Attorney
General's lawsuit became public that I
realized what she was trying to tell me
about the packs the study went back
talked to her a lot more and my student
the book is about the misrepresentation
of data and how to to woman to women and
a man spoke up and risk the you know
their careers to do so and what that led
to and the stories in that but I first
became familiar with Donna Howard
because she had called about the misuse
of state funds so that clears up a
little bit it's all the book yes right
on the theme I noticed in your book that
I agree with comment being that drugs
are just one component of treatment for
major mental illness and that talk
therapy and getting support from friends
and relatives or people with mental
illness the latest trend in mental
health now is peers people with lived
experience with mental illness helping
other people or running programs run
Burton called the Boston Resource Center
at Boston Medical we're a drop-in people
can come and talk to people and people
will share the side effect profiles that
they've had personally I was on 10 or 20
different medications that never really
worked at all for me until I found one
thing that didn't seem to work that I'm
comfortable taking even though there are
some side effects the question is and I
mean it was a kite for us years ago I
used to do a lot of talk therapy they
did a lot more and when you read in your
book every time you see a psychiatrist
it seems that you see them for 15 or 20
minutes and they've got a new diagnosis
and a new medication and they're
changing this and changing that I don't
think 15-20 minutes is enough time to
really make you're not getting any data
you're not looking at the history you're
not looking at their family you're not
looking at the other components of their
life and that's the ongoing story right
when people and I wonder if you could
comment on that and what what the
possible remedies to that could be well
I mean a lot of this has to do with
managed care and the squeeze on health
care reimbursements starting in the
early 90s so it became a lot easier for
people who were you know for doctors to
prescribe any depressants and drugs
rather than to spend the time to talk in
talk therapy and and and for some people
psychotherapy didn't work and while the
drugs did for me I mean many studies
show that the best thing is for many
people is both its you know real
concentrated psychotherapy and also
medication to some extent that works
particularly for people with clinical
depression so
but the problem is is that our
healthcare system and that's a whole
nother story is not set up to reimburse
people for psychotherapy so too often
and then a lot of people don't there's a
stigma about therapy and so they go to
their patient they say you know I want a
quick fix I want a magic bullet and the
doctor either doesn't know or doesn't
tell them about the full spectrum of
side effects and so they'd rather take
the pill and in some cases they do want
the therapy but their health insurance
isn't going to reimburse them for it and
it's cheaper just to prescribe a pill so
all of these reasons factored into why
they're you know so many people are
taking very strong medication these days
for a myriad of ills yes oh and then I'm
sorry oh that's all right but if this
your standard don't you think that some
of the problems have evolved because the
government has cut back on funding
I mean NIH and whatever I mean this well
there's always been a proliferation of
some scientists as some researchers and
some labs fabricating results you know
but if there's if there's a greater
amount of this going on I think some of
it has to do with the fact that the
federal government isn't giving money
enough money to research I think you're
right I mean I think people like the
doctor Marcia Angell
and Jerry a Bourne and Jerome kassir who
have written very good policy books
about this issue believe that there
needs to be more federal funding of drug
research so that you don't get all of
the clinical trials funded by drug
companies who have a vested interest in
a positive outcome but we're spending
our money other ways then where perhaps
we should yes hi hi dr. Condry hi
Allison thanks for your book this
conversation brings up a lot of stories
that I could share but I'm just gonna
share one here and that's on the level
of the drug companies themselves and
particularly in a drug Paxil
paxil has a very interesting history it
came when it came out it already came
into a very crowded SSRI market so that
was marketed as an antidepressant but
Glaxo said hey we're gonna market this
as an anti-anxiety drug and so what they
did was they began to promote it for
something that was really relatively
unknown at the time called social
anxiety disorder and their first major
promotion of this was the at the tagline
imagine being allergic to people and
then they produced this they produced
the problem they argued they came out
with checklists about what in fact you
would need to have to go ask your doctor
if your social anxiety disorder and then
they promoted it for people who couldn't
speak well in public or had trouble at
cocktail parties or other things like
this so one of the issues that comes
here is not just that and on the
university level we have academic
researchers and a whole system of
approving drugs that's questionable but
we have a whole marketing system to put
more and more people in the way of
getting these drugs for very everyday
kind of problems some people of the
critics of paxil have said this is a
drug they say it's a drug for social
phobia people say no no this is a drug
for shyness so it sits as a large larger
set of issues here than the drug then
simply the drug companies reproducing
their own research in a certain ways but
actually marketing it so more and more
people are part of their potential
customers you're absolutely right and
Peter Conrad has written an excellent
book Peter what's the name of the yep
because I cited in my ear
right and he so he's a professor at
Brandeis and so if you're interested in
this issue you should definitely pick up
its book his book it's really good but
that's absolutely right and in fact the
prologue of my book I talked about a 15
year old girl who saw a television
commercial you know she was shy she had
a little anxiety around kids her own age
and so she saw a television commercial
showing a young boy her age who was also
shy and after taking paxil suddenly he
was a social butterfly he was popular
carefree so she said she went to her
family doctor and said I want paxil so
that opens up you know as dr. Conrad
talks about that opus of a whole the
whole issue of direct-to-consumer
advertising which can be extremely
misleading and the United States is only
one of two developed countries in the
world that allow direct-to-consumer
advertising so and it's often extreme
you know the way they do they do side
effects but they speed it up they divert
people with music they they have visuals
that divert people's attention when they
read the side effects so there's many
ways in which they are deceptive when it
comes to fully informing people about
side effects on these commercials so
that's a whole other ball of wax but I
think Alex one more yes Jill good good
Providence daily or whatever it is
that's a very good question too because
it's in Providence and the Providence
Journal writes nothing bad about brown
and in fact they're very much in cahoots
I found this from reporting when I was
at the globe that the people who come to
me and say you know don't bother going
to Providence Journal and that I saw
that they didn't they never ran negative
stories even when I had broken that
story about Keller and the state funding
the Providence Journal I think they did
an editorial but they never ran their
own stories I mean they really you know
Brown is a major employer and and I'm
not saying all of brown this is the
brown Medical School okay
but there so that's why she didn't go to
the Providence Journal she knew better
the reason why she came to the globe she
told me was because she had been reading
a lot of my articles on mental health
and on the mental-health cutbacks by the
well administration and she lived in
Massachusetts so she got the Boston
Globe so she felt like she knew me and
she called but even when she first
called she just left a message you know
with the city desk and it just by for
truth but the reason she cooperated with
me once I finally got back to her was
because she knew my name and trusted
what I had written so it was just luck
of the draw so somebody's getting done
good from okay that's great all right so
I think any other last questions
it's a tremendously intense mental
health care history - probably one of
the most extraordinarily intense in the
country it begs the question my father's
a physician always says that physicians
are like anybody else 90% of people are
terrible at what they do so for for that
reason you know as a journalist where do
you go for sources where do you go for
information that is written in normal
plain English that average people can
read and seek out that explains at least
some of this knowing that not all of it
does make it out but just some sort of
source and I think that's that may be a
good way to sort of close out the well I
would if you're being prospective you're
prescribed a drug the first thing you
should do is go to the FDA website WWF
DEA gov and there look up the drug and
they'll tell you whether it's got at
least got black box warnings they won't
tell you a lot but they will tell you
some of that I also you know subscribe
to some of the medical journals like the
New England Journal of Medicine
now the original articles can be dense
going but they have they do endeavor to
make it readable the newspapers also try
to translate some of this although as we
all know newspapers are being downsized
these days and they they just have fewer
resources particularly to do the kind of
investigative journalism that I was
lucky enough to do when I was at the
globe there many fewer reporters at the
Boston Globe who can do this now and
that have the resources they just are
doing other things there's just fewer
reporters for the Boston Globe and
that's true of every newspaper in the
country so unfortunately a lot of the
best stuff is getting written and in
books like Peter Conrad's and other
books where people bring this across so
I would I guess say do web searches to
try to find out who's writing books
who's writing articles who's writing
very informed blogs they're actually a
lot of good blogs about the
pharmaceutical industry my blog but you
know on a little you know not as regular
as I should but like there's something
called farm a lot which is a really good
blog and they cover the pharmaceutical
industry very very well so from and
there's something called ion FDA that's
also a blog so
there are people out there covering it
but it's tough these are a lot of these
are people farm a lot is owned by Star
Ledger in Newark New Jersey so they have
the resources to do a little digging but
a lot of the bloggers don't and they're
just you know kind of cutting off the
surface and but you can find it in books
you can find it in blogs and from
reading your your newspapers yes one
more question is that good
okay sure hi thank you so much for your
book I'm lucky enough that I learned
that you would be here I have a daughter
who almost died from paxil but she was
also taking nine other medications at
the same time in good care I suppose at
newton-wellesley and she had been in
other places but I want to know first if
you are if you have awareness about the
International Coalition for drug
awareness doctor and Traci who does
tremendous work and I discovered her
after I spent a night on the Internet
convinced my daughter was gonna die
because she had a four and a half months
chest pain which eventually after being
told that she only had anxiety the
doctor knew the world's we finally said
you know maybe it's the paxil because
I've had a patient who even had surgery
or never had the pain go away why don't
we start going down the pack sue and in
about four days the pain subsided but
that mistake was that she said in
two-and-a-half weeks she could get off
the paxil and we're in a horrible
rollercoaster and what dr. Traci
stresses as how it needs to be six two
months to a year maybe longer so I want
to thank you and I have a quiet last
question do you think we could dream of
nonprofit drug companies
[Laughter]
we live in a capitalistic society and
you have to give companies a profit
motive so that they will develop drugs I
mean but I do think that there needs to
be more oversight of the system so it
definitely needs to be more oversight
because it's not just the
antidepressants it's not just the
antipsychotics this is happening with a
lot of other drugs with Vioxx with
vytorin and anti cholesterol drug with
Procrit and R&S anti anemia drugs where
again and again the drug companies are
know that there are more severe side
effects and they're not letting the
public know about that so it just keeps
happening unfortunately because of the
business model of many pharmaceutical
companies yeah yeah
SSRIs stories dot-org okay and drug
awareness org both put out by the people
who work for the International Coalition
for drug awareness SSRI stores org has
more than two thousand stories of people
who either committed suicide or became
violent because of these drugs alright
thank you very much and thank you so
much for coming
go downstairs
okay yep okay now do you need to get
this off because I've got to go sign
books and Alison bass writes on medicine
technology and science for the Boston
Globe ms bass has received awards from
the National Alliance for the mentally
ill and the National Mental Health
Association for her reporting she's
taught journalism courses at Brandeis
University and Boston University for
more information about alison bass visit
her blog at alison - bass dot blog
spot.com